son histoire pourrait faire penser un
conte de fées madame de maintenon est
née françoise d'aubigné dans une prison
à niort avant de connaître les coulisses
du pouvoir va connaître une ascension
exceptionnelle puisque elle va traverser
les années 560 en devenant la
gouvernante des enfants du roi et de
madame de montespan et finalement le roi
qu'il a dédaigné un petit peu va
finalement se rapprocher d'elle et elle
va épouser celui qu'on appelait à
l'époque le plus grand roi du monde en
783 devient une presque rennes et va
vivre à versailles l'exposition penser
de manière chronologique emmène dans les
allées du pouvoir dans l'appartement
qu'elle occupe à l'époque elle ya vécu
35 ans est un lieu assez emblématique
puisque louis xiv lui a octroyé cet
appartement au moment où lui donne une
charge auprès de la dauphine c'est à
dire la brute 2014
il trouve cette astuce pour lui donner
un appartement on a beau être la
maîtresse du roi on ne peut pas être
logés gratuitement à versailles une
reine dont on sait finalement peu de
choses avec une soixantaine d'oeuvres et
de documents les équipes du château
replace madame de maintenon dans
l'histoire
[Musique]